let's talk about Brittany Greiner she's
returning to the only WNBA team she has
ever played for Source confirms the CBS
news that the Phoenix Mercury will
resign the eight-time All-Star to a
one-year contract the deal comes less
than three months after Griner was freed
from a Russian prison the 32 year old
free agent led the Mercury to the WNBA
finals in 2021 Greiner was then detained
in Russia for 10 months after Customs
officials arrested her at a Moscow
airport finding Vape cartridges
containing cannabis oil in her luggage
when Greiner was released in December
she wrote on Instagram that she intended
to play basketball again for the Mercury
nice to see her back yeah her livelihood
she's so talented and I think that was
like the number one question once she
got settled like do you think she'll
play basketball
I hope she's getting paid 106. yeah but
I mean so then you don't have to go you
don't have to go overseas you have to
look at endorsements that will come and
I think her story if you didn't know
Brittany greiner's name before you know
it now so it'll bring fans hopefully
hopefully good point